so there's a huge backlash of defunding
the police voters in minneapolis sending
a big message about crime after
overwhelmingly rejecting an amendment to
dismantle the city's police department
and replace it with a department of
public safety it comes as the nation
faces a crime wave violent crime up
across the board including in cities
like minneapolis suffering from rising
cases and homicide and
robbery and rape as well
judge
the the mayor of minneapolis who did
defend the police he won re-election
right today as well that was announced
but this whole idea of defunding the
police
minneapolis we know was ground zero and
then that failed today well you know
people say that all politics is local
right and i can understand them saying
that but i think that minneapolis sent a
message nationally this is ground zero
of what happened to george floyd 17
months ago and it spurred all kinds of
outrage in the country and
internationally and justifiably so but
the criminal justice system worked
someone was indicted he was tried and he
was convicted all right and that's how
america works so now what we have are a
few naysayers who want to get rid of
police departments we've already gotten
rid of something like 250 police
officers who've left the force so
there's an uptick in crime in
minneapolis the the inner city doesn't
want the police to be defunded and the
number reduced and instead what we have
are people like ilhan omar and keith
ellison saying let's get rid of the
police no the people don't want that 57
percent don't want that and across the
country people are saying there's no
cash bail doesn't work we can't get rid
of the police they are the ones who are
defending us and so this is you know
where chop and chaz and all these
anti-police and anti-american locations
were but people are saying we're getting
killed we're getting becoming victims of
violent crime you're not getting rid of
the police no matter what your
progressive agenda nonsense is well
geraldo ilhan omar the congresswoman
from the area she actually tweeted a
complaint about the police saying that
they were reneging on their
responsibility and their commitment to
the community and that was why the
violent crime has gone up you know i am
friends with lots of cops in fact i'm
speaking uh bluecoat's a big charity in
cleveland on monday night
the fact of the matter is elon omar
has no connection with cops only when
you need them that's when you want them
she has no idea what cops lives are like
but i i just go back to all politics is
local i think you were right judge in
the beginning all politics is all local
look at cleveland i come back to that
jason bibb the guy who won
very strong against the cops we had four
murders over the weekend in cleveland we
have more than 150 this year and still
the issue twenty years one city against
seven other situations that i pointed
out
whether it's virginia or new jersey or
texas or seattle i'm queasy about trance
cleveland cincinnati progressives uh
were uh you know they won
so let's not over generalize i i really
do think that the republicans have a lot
of work to do and i think democrats
jesse you brought up this tiny annoying
republicans
about trends that would explain the
mustache geraldo
[Laughter]
i assume this is out of style
this is why people hate politicians
because as the judge so eloquently
described there was a lot of turmoil
after george floyd and the politicians
think oh my god i have to do something i
don't know what to do but i have to do
something and they end up doing
something which was wrong they listened
to a few screamers on the streets they
took a slogan and they put it into law
and that caused a huge crime wave and
then when they put it to the people in a
proposition the people rejected it they
refunded the police now dana how many
times in the history of this great
nation
have the politicians done the opposite
of what the people wanted
you could say that the history of this
country is that
now how easy it is it to be a politician
in a democracy people make fun of this
putting your finger in the air yeah
there's nothing wrong with that you just
listen to what your voters want and then
you do what they want how hard is that
it shouldn't be that hard i mean
that's what i would do okay but we'll
keep that in mind that'll be a good
campaign commercial yeah i'll do what
you want don't do what you want vote
it's a democracy right you think that
this ends the defund the police movement
i hope so i mean mentally ill han
i heard she was incredibly distraught
she's actually moving to philadelphia no
yeah it's the city of brussels it's a
city of brotherly love
i'm shay
i love it if this was a necessary
correction it's like the person taking
the steering wheel from a drunk driver
the question is is it too late to really
plow into the crowd minneapolis looks
terrible and i i mean they need a full
like rest complete restoration to get
their city back because i mean the
liberal crime policies the way they just
let the place burn is terrible we still
have the no cash bail all around we've
got to get rid of that i'm happy that
the new york city
elected a cop as a mayor and i hope i
hope he acts like a cop we need more
police but
democrats have a choice
you can keep going too far keep driving
into the race-based abyss or you can
finally come to your senses and stop
listening to these radicals or your
party is going to be as dead as keith
olbermann's career oh
man they can't say they weren't warned
yes we've warned them many times the
number one show
in all of cable news has been telling
you that's right
keith is on the line
well oh yeah he's not very nice actually
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else